you know life chair
thank you right may i welcome all
members of the present and members of
the public to this
special meeting of the community and
resources committee
with basically one item on the agenda
first of all we'll have apologies for
absence
no apologies chair but two members not
currently present
yes that's right proper job
uh public contributions i've not been
notified of anyone wishing to speak
and we've got months to be read out so
we move right on to
declarations of interest
which members should be aware
if they have financial or other
involvement in anything
they have to declare it and
keep clear of the meeting
right item four is agreement with the
agenda between parts one and two
as i understand it there is nothing
which is private and confidential
to the council so therefore no part two
item five is urgent matters i have
no urgent matters to bring forward
so we move on to the one item number six
the recommendation from internal
overview and scrutiny committee
about free car parking we have
received a written report which i guess
sean is going to speak to but we'll find
out
thank you chair yes um i'll speak to
this one uh
members will of course be familiar that
we started back in january
uh sorry january feels like january july
with a notice of motion from councillor
mcgoff to provide some
free parking to support businesses in
their response to
covid we've had several meetings to
discuss
free parking since then the last time
you as a committee met to discuss
this you resolved to provide two hours
free parking for the months of
october and november in the car park
specified within the report
that decision was called to scrutiny
uh which at which the subject was given
a
a a really strong airing
and actually scrutiny have made
recommendation back to you that
you you consider an alternative um their
their proposal would be that you uh
provide a second hour of free parking so
that
parkers would provide pay for the first
hour and have a second hour
free and they've also made a
recommendation to you about how that
should be funded
and that should come from the balance of
the new homes bonus
or what was the new homes bonus grants
fund so
it's for your committee chair to
consider the
recommendation of overview and scrutiny
what i've tried to do in the report is
is give in the conclusion section is
give you some
pointers as to what might happen over
various
um if what if you concluded various
outcomes
uh happy to take any questions chair but
it's over to you
to debate the recommendation from
scrutiny
thank you right i'm throwing it open to
the meeting councillor mcgoff first shot
he's the one who put forward
the original proposal thank you very
much uh mr chairman good afternoon to
you
uh mr chairman i do believe it's
groundhog day on torridge
uh i'm gonna stick with my original
motion that i submitted to cnr
um i i think it would have started back
in 29th for june i think
or maybe it was early july i believe
that two hours free car parking
is the easiest way to manage um i was
present at the
scrutiny committee one question i would
like to say to
the chairman peter watson who called it
in
we do have finances to fund this and
it's
going to come for the new homes bonus
pot um and on there but the
money coming back tenfold it comes back
to my local economy i look back at what
i said
notes and it says local economy and my
priorities
my priority is to represent the people
who elected me into my position
they come first and tdc comes second a
very close second but my
electorate come first for me so i stick
by my original motion of two hours free
car parking
um and obviously don't accept anything
the scrutiny
did say thank you
right uh next hand up i saw was
chancellor hutchings
who's not a member of the committee but
entitled to speak
i think that's right admit all right
john you i am a member you are a member
of the committee my apologies
um yeah i i have read the report and
obviously what scrutiny have said um i
don't believe that
the second hour free actually um does
what we intend for it to do
um the whole point i've said about is
there being a charge
um it's not about the amount um
so by making a first out or the second
hour free you still pay the first the
point is of making
it free um i did originally say i
definitely support one hour
um but um i think the one hour
paying one hour free doesn't really add
up to what i was hoping to get so i'd
like the second dermis proposal for the
two hours free parking
and just a question about the scrutiny
um
i thought scrutiny had to either agree
or disagree with
um with what we had put forward and i
didn't realize they can come back with
with an
alternative and if we should vote today
or question really if we should vote
today um does this mean scrutiny can
then come back again
because i can see this going backwards
and forwards backwards and forwards with
no
uh no decision being made which would be
rather sad because what we're trying to
do is help those shopkeepers now
thank you mr chair thank you councillor
bushby
thank you chair councillor hutchins has
just summed up very nicely
my feelings on this and i agree with
the uh councilman goff's uh proposal
so five item five on the recommendations
uh the resolution of community resources
to provide two hours at any time
in the day free parking the endorse
so that's what i um i shall be voting
for
to support the original motion thank you
thank you councillor bright
thank you can i ask sean if we've got
any figures for this year's parking
between
the section where we weren't we're gonna
do a free parking and now
so we can see what the public opinion is
for the economy
you know is there more people going out
parking or less so we can get a rough
trajectory between this year and last
year same period
do we have anything in that kind of
capacity
uh chair i don't have it with me today
um
we i can say that in certain instances
and david's put his finger up he can
probably add more to this in a second
there are certain places certain car
parks that have achieved more this year
than they would in a normal circumstance
um and others that have done less well
but i can't speak with any
um certainty about overall figures but i
i would defer to david who's
looking to come in if that's okay chair
hi yeah we've estimated at the moment
that we'll be down on car parking by
just over half a million pounds for the
financial year
i mean the last two months car parking
has actually
been slightly above target i think
that's mainly to do with the westwood
home and apple door
um car parks if you're honest in the
visitor numbers but obviously we still
got the legacy
from when the car parts were shut um in
at lockdown in sort of really the april
may june
period uh of course as members may be
aware we will receive some compensation
from central government from that but we
do have to bear the first five percent
and they'll compensate us for 75 pence
in the pound
thereafter but it's quite clear in their
guidance they won't compensate us for
any lost car parking income
where we've made a decision not to
charge or not to collect
here chancellor lock
yeah can stacy come back on the point
that was made just now can
um ons come back
and with another proposal then is that
in the constitution
and if this one is you know agreed or
rejected can they come back again
yeah i can i can come in chair on that
point um
ons can make recommendations um and
if cnr don't agree with ons's
recommendation
um then the correct protocol um would be
for the matter to be referred to full
council
for the decision to be made so that's
where
we would be heading today if if c and r
weren't agreeable
to ons recommendation
okay so if cnr
agrees internal's recommendation what
happens because
i'm looking at this we're well into
october already if we've got to go to a
full council
that's not going to be until the end of
november so this is everything's shot
down in flames if we're not careful
chair shall i come back on that
so if if cnr uh agree with ons
recommendation today then it will be
implemented
today um if they don't then it has to be
referred to full council for full
council to make make the decision
as to whether to go with cnr original
motion or ons recommendation
and when is next full council
tonight
the next scheduled full council is the
second of november
thank you right councillor james
all right thank you chair i'm i'm gonna
be slightly different to everybody else
and i
was going to go with ons recommendation
partly because it can be implemented
straight away
if we go into november we've lost
october
and as i understand it we would have to
have a report
done and presumably we won't be able to
claim
free parking in october we would then
have to move into december
um and obviously december usually
particularly in biddeford
and perhaps not so much holdsworthy in
torrington it's a busy month
um and i just feel that if we go back to
ons
that they've done what they're supposed
to do which is to account for the
finance
um which we hadn't done at cnr meetings
in the past
it it's fortuitous in a way that we've
now got money coming back in
if we use all that money for the two
hours there won't be any money left for
um to put back into the community grant
scheme
so as it stands at the moment we could
do
both the free parking and restore the 2
000 pound members
grant so and i just think that i
listened in on
overview and scrutiny i thought
counselor newton's was a
sensible suggestion in in view of
everything
and i was prepared to support it um
so that's my point of view
council of dart
thank you chair um yeah just to say that
i'm
i read in the report that um the
claw back from the parishes um
which i'm absolutely up in arms about i
think that's disgusting
um is now going to be put into this free
car parking scheme is that right if i've
understood it correctly
um i actually think this free car
parking thing was a really good
idea in principle in the beginning of
this whole outbreak
i now feel this is absolutely wasting
all of our time
as well as our officers time and it's
costing us a fortune
in resource just to provide these
flipping agendas
and not to mention officer time in the
meetings
we've taken away from our parish
councils what they'd
actually put in reserve to serve the
community as this pandemic progresses
which it
is progressing and now you're looking to
take that money away from the parishes
put it in as a supplement for this car
parking
and if you do it as the second hour
free actually are people even gonna know
are they that interested i really don't
think they are i think we've lost the
plot on this completely
i think we're laughing stock and i'm
embarrassed and i've stopped reporting
it to my parishes
so get a grip make a decision and stick
to it
and please if you're going to give out
money in a pandemic
for goodness sake make it clear if
there's going to be a clawback option
because parishes were actually really
prudent
in keeping money to one side for
whatever is to come
and all of a sudden they had to spend it
and i know in the report it says
oh the figures aren't up to date because
lots of parishes
actually suddenly put in spending well i
endorsed that because i think that was
wholly wrong and i'm disgusted at
torridge
councillor mcgough
i totally agree it counts to the doc
there are some of the points she made
about
let's make a decision on it it's been
going that's why i call it groundhog day
it's been going on for so long
how many reports did officers need to
present to councillors
i think we've had four or five reports
coming in so far the idea was to about
the business is within the towns
torrenton holzer v
and biddeford you know i'm trying hard i
don't give up on things anyway i'm quite
tenacious and good job i don't give up
because it goes round around on it
the money is sufficient enough in a new
home's bonus pot
i've looked through the figures now
chlorine stuff in parishes
i i don't agree with that character dart
i think that's absolutely madness
this is this is supposed to be
implemented that should help the benefit
of business actually in the public
through this pandemic which is only
getting worse now
for once our life you know let's give
something back to the public and so they
keep saying things off them the figure
of 72 thousand pound will not come out
at 72
000 pain let's get a grip on this one
here
it's going to be less it's going to be
considerably less and i'd like to see
that when we come jen total figure of it
just
hopefully we make a decision today and
we don't keep going round around houses
chairman thank you very much i listen to
everybody else especially the next one
i'm really looking forward to listening
chancellor christie thank you yes
um i voted here for the two hours free
but that was months ago
and i'm afraid as uh you said councillor
hicks
time seems to have overtaken the whole
scheme
um i read through the suggestions from
ons and
i agree with councillor james i think
they are the right way to go now
because one of the things which was
always said that if you gave an hours
free parking that wasn't enough
people would come in have a cup of
coffee try and do some shopping and then
rush back to their cars
if the second hour is free then i think
that
solves that problem um i heard what
councilman goff said in his initial
statement about you know this is for the
community
i have to point out i represent the same
ward as council and golf and
a third of our ward do not own cars
and if we're gonna subsidize car owners
to this extent it does seem a little
unfair
um however if they're willing to pay for
the first hour and then get the second
hour free i haven't got a problem with
that so i'm gonna
um our second counselor james on his
suggestion that we go with rns
thank you
right thank you now we come councillor
leather not a member of the committee
but with full rights to speak
well i was always opposed to the
original recommendation from cnr
um that you're gonna give two hours
free at any time of the day on all those
car parks
now as sean carney reported to cnr
at the time most tickets that are sold
are one hours
or two hour tickets if you give two
hours free any time of the day
it will cost this council a fortune and
i think the
buy one get one free which counseling
newton proposed at ons
is is the only way to go and it can be
implemented straight away
if you don't accept that recommendation
tonight
then it'll have to go to a meeting in
november and you've lost all october
anyway then
so you know i don't think enough work
was done on what two hours at any time
of the day
would cost this council it would be a on
a on him for
we couldn't afford it i don't think or
we'd lose a lot of money
right chancellor newton also i'm not a
committee member but entitled to speak
uh thank you chair i just thought i i
would
say a couple of things seeing as has
been pointed out i
i was i proposed the uh
reworded motion at ons um
i i made that that proposal
having listened carefully to the debates
in cnr
and ons and the the one
thing that i pulled out of it which has
just been
reiterated actually was the
justification
was actually the increased time that it
took
people because of covid restrictions
queuing etc etc and
that was largely the justification and
as sean said and described in his report
he referred to dwell time the amount of
and
the longer that people will hang around
in
a town centre the more they're inclined
to spend
or shop or whatever and the argument was
made
that actually because coveted
restrictions
were making everything longer people
were actually having to rush back to
their cars
quicker and therefore didn't have that
dwell time
and that was the justification behind
my proposal to say right put in
a second hour free so you're increasing
the dwell
time um it also has some
impact on the financial exposure uh
uh that we we have from from this
and therefore controls it a bit um can i
just make one other point saying it was
made really in defense of
of the council i i know that at the time
when the kobe
grants were given out to the parish
councils
it was stated very clearly that actually
any money not spent
would be clawed back i'm not demanding
the merits of that at all
but it was stated and i was at a parish
meeting when the parish clerk
using torridge uh material read out what
the terms of it were so
it's been stirred from the outset that
there's no surprise in clawback as i
said you can debate the merits uh that's
different but um
just to defend our officers uh it was
there thank you
thank you newton councillor locke
yeah i just agree with what council
newton just said with regards to the
claw back of the
um amounts that were paid to the
parishes it's going to be deducted from
their first half precept payment for
this
uh coming year so everyone was well
aware of that
i mean i think timing is of the essence
now if we don't make a decision today
and we don't go with
um ons decision then someone said we
aren't wasting another couple of months
but looking on the gloomy side no
another
moment in the can of worms if govid
cases increase within the area we may be
well
on a lockdown again and we lose all
football because people won't be allowed
to come out so unless we act
now it won't be any benefit
again
okay uh we'll move on counselor wiseman
thank you very much chair well this has
been quite an interesting soap opera
isn't it
going back and forth on what have you um
it was quite interesting at the start
that every
agency we we had evidence from
that um could speak to us said don't do
it
doesn't pay it's a waste of time the
chair
even said that to us from evidence he
had the leader of the council sorry
but yet we still plowed ahead with this
rash irrational decision
and it is irrational there are forces of
foot which are far
greater and make far greater difference
for people's decision
whether to go to the big towns and shop
than whether they can get an hour's
second hours free parking or not
so what do we do now we're going to
throw a fortune at this
irrational decision so what do we do we
spend
possibly 70 possibly 43.
everybody it seems to me from what i've
listened to this evening
this afternoon seemed to be set on this
idea
so i think all that i can do now is vote
to try and reduce the amount of
financial damage this is going to do
to our finances and therefore our
our electors i i'm left with no choice
disappointing as that seems but i think
i'll have to go with a second hour
free compromise
gentler laws good afternoon chairman
uh well one overriding thing is
what is it going to cost torridge
now i support uh
my leader's recommendation
but it's not as bad as you think because
because of covert westwood ho
people like braddock's holiday camps
they're still full our parking grounds
are still busy
so westwood ho i hope will play its part
in reducing
uh any financial loss i don't think it's
going to be as great as we think
um but there i i support the leader's
recommendation
and i hope this will draw it to a
conclusion this afternoon
and and support the shopkeepers
thank you chad thank you councillor
bright
thank you again uh yeah i got it this
time uh
can we get confirmation from the
officers that this scheme whichever we
go for
is advertised sufficiently to the
members of the public and also that is
put
on the parking meters so that there's no
you know
ambiguity with it as it could have been
last time
and chair i can respond yeah we can um
we can obviously
if you resolve to provide any free
parking initiative
promote that on the website we can also
put uh posters by the
on the charge boards so the notice
boards next to the
um to pay and display machines so that
people are very clearly instructed that
the second hour or even two hours free
parking
are free
councillor hutchings
can i ask for the chair um can an
alternative um
suggestion be put forward at this stage
you can put it forward but by the time
it goes to
this committee scrutiny and that it'll
be next year before it takes effect
but the only thing is i can see where
this conversation is going and i don't
think the second now really benefits
and if i had to make a choice between a
second hour free or one hour's free
parking i think i'd rather go for one
hour's free parking
which actually is gonna cost or predict
it to cost less
than the second hour free and um and i
my other question on to that is that if
if that isn't a suggestion
um i represent holesworthy and i
personally feel that one hour's free
parking would be
more beneficial than the second hour so
can i put forward a motion specifically
for holesworthy
um for one hour's free parking
should the two hours not go through
would that be to take hold of the out of
any of the other two schemes
well if if as an extra decision
um that i would rather see holes that
get a one hours free parking
but then you know if if people are going
to go with the the second hour
i'd be quite happy to put forward
something for one hour's free parking
which actually is gonna cost thirty
thousand rather than forty three
thousand
but i can see the one hour being more
beneficial than the second hour free
i don't know whether councillors feel
about that
i've got an awful feeling that you 2000
it's gonna be no free parking in whole
city with your proposal
okay chair just to respond it would be
cheaper to have one hour's free parking
than it would be to have the second
that's all i'm saying
yes but by the time it goes through the
committee procedure with scrutiny
calling it in it won't happen
but if the costs are in place as they
are now could that not decision not be
taken
and placed in motion today sorry steve
uh sorry constellations um if a
different recommendation
is made then it would be uh subject to
call in by scrutiny should um members
wish to do so
that's the the way the constitution is
set out because you'll be proposing a
different recommendation
so it may be enacted but it may also be
called in so it's
uh that kind of risk you would run
since i came to the hutchins would you
like to come back on that one please
i just getting bored with the whole lot
of it to be honest
i just you know i just can't i i'm
somewhat
i'm a bit bemused the fact that you know
we're we were voted on as
a as a group of counselors and with the
scrutiny come at the different
a different option which you know as far
as i was concerned they had to make a
decision yes or no
on the on the uh on what we put forward
from cnr so i was a little bit surprised
when actually they came out with a
different option
but that's that's just me i suppose
right counselor james um thank you chair
i have a certain amount of sympathy with
that counselor hutchins but
as coaster newton said one of the things
with what we're doing is trying to
encourage people to stay
and bros a little bit in holdsworthy or
torrington or anywhere else
i think we've reached the stage now
it's took a lot of officer time it's
holding this council up from getting on
and doing what we should be doing
um the i thought ons dealt with it very
well i think
you know it was a good discussion they
actually did what they were supposed to
do was to look at the finance
um and really
with coaster hicks here is that we do
need to make a decision the simplest and
the straightforward decision
and i've never i've always said i would
support it if it didn't cost
council any money i don't believe it
will make a lot of difference
i notice in biddeford on thursday or
friday
all the car parks were full so i don't
know where these extra free
car parking people are going to park i
i've got to be honest i haven't been
into houseworthy
uh for a week or so um but i think
you know the most sensible thing to do
and the pragmatic thing to do
is to go with ons and
get on move it forward and we you'll
have money to give into your directly
into
community schemes and we can start as a
council
concentrating on the other things we've
got in our strategic plan
thank you chair thank you councillor
brenton
chancellor brenton thank you yes it's
just been unmuted thank you
well terry i'm i've always supported the
original proposal
and i still do i do believe that we
should be doing the best we can to
support our principal town in torridge
some of the rural members go out to
oakhampton and other places to shovel
extra
fair enough but here in this core of
torridge
i.e biddeford northern western ho africa
all those places
that we need to support our retail
outlets and they really are struggling
at the moment
so any assistance we can give to support
them we need to do it now before too
many of them go under
they're already closing in biddeford how
much of a ghost town do you need
and if we don't support the retail part
of it then the banks will be using their
excuses
to pull out as well and then one of the
main reasons why people come in
local people i mean come in that too
will be lost
that is a scenario i don't want to see
happen all right so the car parks are
fairly full
now because of course we still have a
lot of late holiday makers around
that's good but coming up to christmas
that will not be the case
i do think we should do what we can to
support them
you know all right it sounds like a lot
of money and i would question some of
the figures i have to say
some of the revenue expectations i would
question them
i have done in the past and never got
any really satisfactory answers but
nonetheless
they are what they are printed down so i
would urge members
to think carefully about what they're
poised to do
thank you councillor brenton our
councillor james
i'll just pick up on council brenton
then are you including
northern and westwood ho in the free
parking though because i thought it was
just biddeford
you know this is just going
becoming farcical you know people on
youtube listening to this must wonder
what we're doing
we've got perfectly sensible costed
proposal
from ons um and we can implement it
it won't be quite tomorrow but it can be
within the next day or two
and we move on um we've we've done what
we can do to
to help the shops um in that respect
there's lots of arguments coaster
christie points out a third of biddeford
people
in his ward don't have cars i know
they're they're essentially
here where we live um but i
i i just think people will spend
whatever it is is it 30 or 60p
for the first hour and then they've got
an hour to miranda around the shops and
see if there's something they like
i think it solves a lot of issues i
think we're just going round in circles
sorry can i respond to that please yep
thank you well firstly i didn't include
northern and westward hoeing that at all
i've
said that these uh areas these towns
rather
and parts of torridge are depend on
biddeford basically for their um
retail shopping so that's quite a
different
scenario all together and i take the
point the counselor christy makes
and yes a lot of people don't have cars
but
if if the towns aren't viable you know
for people with cars don't come in and
shop there
they won't have shops to go to by bus or
in or walk or whatever
you know that's the point i'm trying to
make here is that you do
need a core of retail outlets or
variety of retail uh opportunities
somewhere in your um district area
and biddeford happens to be it thank you
councilman mcguff
thank you mr chairman um just coming on
the back of what council branson said
then uh but
the cars coming into the town centre uh
bitter for specifically i
would point straight to council christie
how do you think most of the visitors
come to the burton art gallery
they don't walk judith gentry said a lot
of its car footfall they actually park
up more across the road
so as cars come into that uh cancer
james i'd like to touch on a point you
just made
you've attracted the 32 36 thousand pain
actually from the council's grants from
2000 to 1000
you decided to take half the money away
i was in an agreement
agreement with it then but it's fine for
you to do that but we already got money
from central government we could have
spent more wisely
and i don't think you've done a great
job on it myself that's my opinion on
that
and i want to touch on where's our point
about the race
that's that's the main thing there and
the money is coming from the new homes
bonus pawn
now david hayes can answer this from it
and answered it truthfully please uh
david hayes but just layman's have
something not true layman's hands please
but he knew i was born
[Music]
that's what i meant and i've actually if
you let me finish i actually just said
that tonight put it in layman's terms
for me and the public thank you
no smoking mirrors forgive me counseling
off i don't actually understand what the
question to me is
could you repeat it
now we got sufficient money in the new
homes bonus spot to support the scheme
and the new homes bonus part comes from
the new
receipt of bui precept
apologies i wasn't unmuted there
apologies uh in its entirety no because
with the balance of the new homes bonus
funding is 54 000.
and if we did the two-hour free parking
that'd be 72 000 pounds
um when we did the in sean's paper there
was a variety of other
pots of money such as the member grant
and the balance and member grants
brought forward
added together they would give us 83 000
pounds
pounds which could fund the 72 000
pounds estimate cost of the free parking
has that answered your question uh
council mcgoff
did i go about that mr chairman
yep mr hayes
spot on that answers my question and the
fact that i don't agree with ken james
taking 36 phases of
asking councillors thank you
councillor james well i just have to
come back there
and thank councilman mcgrath for his
support for me as the leader of the
council
the fact was that we worked out a system
of how we could support the local
communities
we put it through the the procedure i i
know he put in an email to
one member that i control the purse
strings i can assure
all members i don't control the first
strings i put forward suggestions
and they can be adopted by the council
or rejected
we were congratulated we come out very
high plenty of things change
we come up very high in the rate that we
paid out business grants
we've congratulated in the way we got
money out to our community
i know all of a sudden that was the
wrong thing to do
i'm sorry we've done what we thought we
could do
and i think we did it well i'm not over
happy with stuff being clawed back
so if it wasn't clawed back there
wouldn't be enough money
to do what you want to do consumer golf
so
you know we're just going around in
circles here
um and i just want to emphasize i do not
control the purse strings
it's done by the council and that is why
ons is there
to check that when people give money
away it is
checked where that money is going and
there is money there to actually give
away
thank you councilman mcgolf
thank you mr chairman um
counselor james there's no such email
being sent
because i wouldn't send something like
that if i want to say so i pick up the
phone
and tell people straight um and let's
touch on their business grants that
money came from central government
and the officers at toro has done a
grand job actually distributing that and
actually email saying what a good job
they've done
so don't get spinning out on me trying
to run the offices down because i'm not
i just said i wasn't happy with you
taking a 36 phase and write the options
of asking the counselors where that
money came from
nothing to do and he did a good job but
the money came for central government i
know we were really quick on it
and we did discretionary grants as well
i've actually had two or three people
with discretion grants and
mr hayes himself and i've done a
fantastic job i'm not running officers
doing so don't get spit on that on me
we've got pixie led but councillor james
come back again
well and for the last time but just to
say
i did not give away the 36 000 it was
part of a scheme
and what i will do when we finish the
meeting council mcgrath i'll send
everybody a copy of the email you sent
to mr whatever his name was
saying that i controlled the purse
strings so
thank you and thank you for your support
councillor locke well i'm sure we're
straying off the whole subject
i would ask the committee now to please
go to the vote
i agree councillor dog
yeah can i just make the point on the
claw back because we did all we all
voted for
at cnr um and you know i condone the
claw back but
just to make the point we are still in
this pandemic
it is not over and we do not know what
is going to happen
so to recklessly spend money is stupid
to considerately spend money is sensible
this is wasting money which is not
sensible
so let's take a decision i'm probably
going to have to vote for it because
otherwise we're going to keep going
round around in circles but i really
don't condone spending all this money on
the free
car parking just to give the impression
to our residents
you know i actually really hope it makes
a difference to our shops because
they're going to need it this pandemic
is here for the long haul
chancellor brown not a committee member
but welcome to speak
thank you chair i just want to make the
point of what i observe in torrington at
the moment
and that is that people parking in the
car park yes
they come into town and they actually
have to stand outside the shops
and wait until they're invited in
because of the social distancing so one
hour really
isn't enough for them to go post office
or another shop
and then perhaps wander at the pannier
market so i would want to see the second
hour
um free thank you chair chancellor
hutchings
um mr chair this time a technical
question really
um scrutiny have come back with a way of
the set of the
um of the money being funded which we've
been told should we
go with that one today that can start
tomorrow
but david haye just came back with how
the 72 2000 could be
where that could come from so what's the
difference why would why could that not
start straight away
because david said there was 84 000
available
so why isn't that boy could that not go
ahead today the same as the um
i think we're confusing two issues here
council hutchins as i understand it
oh internal authenticity have made a
recommendation if you approve that today
we can start if however you reject the
recommendation for an internal over
scrutiny it will then have to go to full
council which is um
is it the second of november i believe
uh to make a decision
we have estimated that 84 83 000 pounds
set aside
to fund whichever decision the
councillors make if you make the
decision for the
first hour free um pay for the first
hour second hour free we estimate the
cost to be
43 000 if you give two hours free
parking we estimate the cost to be
is it 72 000. seventy two thousand
so we've estimated funding of eighty
three thousand
the thing about today or tomorrow is
depending on whether you agree
to um concur with the recommendation for
an internal over increased scrutiny it's
not about the finances per se
does that explain correctly to you i
thought the reason it had to go back was
because there were no finances but okay
you're
okay so why would so questions why does
it have to go back to full council
if the finance is there for both um
because of the constitution
simple as that okay senator pennington
thank you chair um given that tonight
we're going to have a question from
simon newton stating the kibbles
job cost us 419 hours
how many hours as we spent on car parks
and we need urgently to move on because
this is becoming a fiasco
please can the committee make a decision
and have a clear
step forward stop batting it around
because 419 hours i think will probably
be exceeded by our officers now
we're doing future reports and i think
we need to you know
on what might be a maximum of 83
thousand
it it it's all out of proportion and i'm
very concerned by the way this is going
thank you chair including that
thank you chair only briefly but it's
been proposed and seconded that you
that the committee accepts the overview
and scrutiny recommendation
councillor brown who's a member of the
committee moves that you go to the vote
and that should be happening sure with
respect
uh i've heard you all i have actually
two motions
put forward chancellor mcgough that his
original one applies
and the second one from overview and
scrutiny
as i understand it i have to put both of
them to the vote
which i propose to do now
yes help please um chad um councillor
mugoff's original motion still stands
anyway um
so we've got the proposal to accept ons
recommendations so that's the one that
needs to go to the vote
if that fails then they will both go to
full council for a decision so i don't
think we need another vote on councillor
mcgoff's
motion you just need to do the uh vote
on whether to accept ons
recommendation if that motion fails then
it'll go to full council and full
council will make a decision
on both proposals thank you stacy very
clear
so i'm moving to the vote um
and that is that we accept the internal
overview and scrutiny committee
recommendation of a second hour
free in october and november
recorded vote please thank you chair
councillor brenton
against councillor bright
boar councillor bushby
against councillor christie
or pencil a dart
for penciller hicks
for councillor hutchins
against councillor james
councillor laws or penciller lock
or councillor mcgrath
against councillor wiseman
or
chair that's eight four and
four against there we are now it can be
publicized
free second hour parking in
biddeford hall city and torrington
for the rest of october and november
thank you for your attendance and we'll
see you again at that past six
everyone for the check can we just
charge miss check we just asked when um
is there a date that we're going to
officially go for i know i said it could
start tomorrow it's not going to is it
just an official date
start date uh chair i'll go back in
tomorrow morning obviously and start the
process it'll probably take a couple of
days so i can advise you to probably
tomorrow of the start date but i would
hope it would be later this week
thank you okay
end of meeting i declare it closed at
14 46.